Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Alkışlar)
Merhaba ben Neslican Tay.
20 yaşındayım.
20. yaşımın yalnızca
30'uncu gününde burada sizlerleyim.
Herhangi bir konuda uzmanlığım yok,
harika bir kariyerim de yok.
Sadece hayat hikâyem var.
Bugün size kendi
hayat hikâyemi anlatacağım.
Çok mutlu bir ailede doğdum.
İnanılmaz hiperaktif, düz duvara tırmanan,
heyecanlı bir çocuktum.
Komşu çocuklarının ezeli rakibiydim.
Hani o her kıyaslama da galip gelen
çocuk vardır ya, kesinlikle o bendim.
Sporcuydum, basketbol oynadım beş yıl.
Aynı zamanda atletizimle ilgilendim.
İyi bir öğrenciydim.
2016'da Fen Lisesi'nden mezun oldum.
İyi bir puan aldım üniversite sınavından
ama çok daha iyisini istiyordum.
Bu yüzden tekrar
hazırlanmaya karar verdim.
Canla başla tekrar
üniversite sınavına hazırlanırken
bacağımda bir ağrı hissettim.
Doktorlar spor yaptığım için
önemsemediler,
kas ağrısıdır, kas yırtığıdır dediler.
Artan ağrılarıma rağmen
doğru teşhis hiçbir zaman konulamadı.
Kanser teşhisi konduğunda
tümör bacağımı sarmış,
kemiğimi aşındırmış, damarımı tıkamıştı.
Türkçesi biz çok geç kalmıştık.
Bu yüzden tedavim oldukça zor geçti.
Şöyle anlatabilirim;
tümörü çıkarmak
için müdahale etmek demek
bacağıma müdahale etmek demek;
tümörün çıkartılması
bacağımı kaybetmek demekti.
Cerrahi müdahaleyle
çıkartılmayan bir tümör
kemoterapiyle küçültülecekti
ve ancak bacağım öyle kurtulabilecekti.
Bu yüzden çok ağır bir
kemoterapi tedavisi gördüm.
Her doz üç günden ve her gün
sekiz saatten oluşan bir tedavi düşünün.
Hâl böyle olunca etkileri de
çok fazla ağırlıkta hissettim.
Sadece saatlerimi onkoloji
koridorlarında geçirmem de değil,
aynı zamanda kemoterapinin
korkunç yan etkilerinden bahsediyorum.
Burada durup saçlarımın tutam
tutam elimde kaldığı o günü,
sudan bile midemin bulandığı zamanları,
enfeksiyon riski yüzünden bir odaya
hapsolmamı anlatmayacağım.
Ya da bir doktorun
karşıma geçip bir çırpıda;
Neslican, bir daha çocuğun olmayabilir,
dediğinde duyduğum
derin acıyı anlatmayacağım.
Ben bugün tüm bunlarla nasıl
baş ettiğimi anlatmak için buradayım.
Öncelikle içselleştirmedim;
çünkü kanser çok büyük bir olay değildi.
Vücudunuzun herhangi bölgesinde
birkaç minik hücrenin
kontrolsüz bölünme evresine
geçmesinden ibaretti yalnızca.
Bu kadar basitti aslında.
Hem ben çok gençtim,
çok sağlıklıydım.
Ailedeki en sağlıklı çocuk
bendim diyebilirim.
Zararlı alışkanlıklarım yoktu
ama ben kanser olmuştum
demek ki herkesin başına
gelebilir, böyle düşündüm.
Ve kanseri gözümde hiç büyütmedim.
Neden ben, neden ben kanser oldum
diye kendimi hırpalamaktansa;
eğer ben seçildiysem kanser için
onu yenebilecek güçte
olduğum içindir diye düşündüm
ve kendime bir söz verdim:
Tümörüm küçülse de büyüse de
beni asla zayıf ve güçsüz
bırakmasına izin vermeyecektim.
Vermedim de.
Kanserin beynimi ele geçirmesine
hiçbir zaman izin vermedim.
İnsanlar maske taktığım için
ne düşünür diye hiç umursamadım.
Maskemi taktım, peruğumu taktım,
makyajımı yaptım kalabalıklara karıştım.
Alışveriş yapmaya gittim,
arkadaşlarımla eğlenmeye gittim,
ailemle piknik yapmaya gittim
ve böylece aylarımı geçirdim.
Doktorlarım beni gördüklerinde
inanamıyorlardı.
Kan testi sonuçlarıma baktıklarında:
- Neslican, şu anda senin
ayakta bile duramaman lazım, diyorlardı.
Bense çılgın danslar yaparak
odalarına giriyordum.
Ablamı doktoruma sessizce;
Neslican ilaç mı kullanıyor,
diye sorduğunu hatırlıyorum.
Ama hayır kullanmıyordum,
psikolojik destekte
hiçbir zaman görmedim.
Çünkü ben her şeyi
beynimde halletmiştim.
Kanser çok büyük bir olay değildi,
herkesin başına gelebilirdi,
sadece tedavisi zor ama ben ona
uyum sağlayabilecek güçteyim, dedim
ve böylece üç ayı geçirdim.
Kemoterapi tedaviye olumlu cevap vermişti
ve tümör biraz da olsa küçülmüştü.
Ama hâlâ bacağım
kurtarılabilecek seviyede değildi.
Böyle olunca daha ağır dozda bir
kemoterapi almama karar verdi doktorlar
ve böylece iki ay daha geçti.
Ağrılarım azalması gerekirken
bir anda artmaya başladı.
Bir terslik vardı.
Şöyle anlatabilirim;
gece bir saatte uykumdan uyanıyordum
ve bir daha asla uyuyamıyordum ağrıdan.
Doktora gidiyorduk, acile gidiyorduk,
serum takılıyordu, ağrı kesici iğneler
ama hiçbir şekilde o ağrılarım dinmiyordu.
Hâl böyle olunca,
bir kanser taramasına
daha girdim ve anladık ki, o
Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nce kabul görmüş
en ağır kemoterapiyi bile
yenmişti tümör.
Böyle olunca doktorum
tüm risklere rağmen
bacağımın derhal çıkartılmasına,
bacağımdaki tümörün
derhal çıkartılmasına karar verdi.
Çünkü aktifleşmiş
bir tümörden tek bir hücre,
hayati bir organa giderse
ve çıkartılamazsa,
bu benim hayatıma mal olabilirdi
ve 20 Temmuz 2017;
hayatımın belki de sonsuza
kadar değiştiği gün.
Bana bir bakın.
Elimde rujum ameliyata gireceğim.
Bacağımla olan son fotoğrafım
olacağına hiçbir zaman inanmıyordum.
Ben bacağımın bende
kalacağına inanıyordum.
Çünkü beş ay boyunca tedavi görmüştüm
bacağım bende kalsın diye.
Çok mutluyum, rujumu sürdüm dedim ki;
aynaya baktığımda kendimi
güzel görmeliyim, diye düşündüm.
Doktorum da uğraşacağını söyledi
bacağımı kurtarmak için.
Ben o küçücük umuda tutunarak
ameliyat sedyesine yattım.
En son yaptığım şeyin;
bacaklarımı, ayaklarımı birbirine
dokundurmak olduğunu hatırlıyorum.
Bir daha asla yapamayacağımı
biliyormuşum gibi, veda eder gibi.
O gün saat dört; uyudum.
Aynı gün saat altı buçukta uyandım.
19 yılımın içindeki en kötü uyanıştı.
Vücudumda korkunç bir ağrı vardı
ve bunun bacağımdaki tümör
çıkartıldığı ve işlem... hani,
başka içeriden protez takıldığı için
var olduğunu saymak istedim
ve saati sordum.
Altı buçuk dedi birisi ve anladım ki
bacağımla uğraşılmamış bile
bacağım kesilmiş.
İşte o an o pikeyi üstümden atışımı
hatırlıyorum, bacağımı göremeyişimi.
Acıyı tüm, tüm hücrelerimde
hissediyorum, nasıl olur diyorum,
nasıl devam ederim bilmiyorum.
Bırakın aynaya bakmayı
kendimi unutuyorum o anda.
Özür dilerim tekrar o günlere gittim.
Nasıl devam ederim bilmiyorum.
Ben yerimde bile duramazdım.
Dört aylıkken yürümeye yani
emeklemeye başlayan insan düşünün
o kadar hareketli bir insandım.
Bacağım yokken nasıl yaşayacaktım.
İlerde iş kadını olduğumda
topuklu ayakkabı giyemeyecek miydim?
İlerde olur da anne olabilirsem
çocuklarımın peşinden
koşamayacak mıydım?
Peki toprak nasıl
kabul edecek bacağımı?
Ben nasıl kabul edeceğim böyle olmayı?
O gün çok...
(Alkışlar)
Acım, tarifsizdi gerçekten.
Acımın altında ezilmemek
için hep üstüne gittim.
Tabii ki belli bir süre tanıdım kendime;
alışmak için, kabullenmek için…
Hep aynanın karşısında
buluyordum kendimi.
Çünkü ben, hayatta kalmak için
bacağını feda etmiş bir kızsam,
hayatımın hakkını
vermeliyim diye düşündüm.
Kendimi böyle de sevmeliyim,
böyle de kabul etmeliyim
ve hayata karışmalıyım.
Bacağımı kaybettikten
yalnızca on beş gün sonra,
o gün dikişlerimi aldırmaya gittim
ve hastanede bana bacağımı verdiler;
siyah bir poşetin içinde.
Ben öndeyim, bacağım bagajda
ve öyle gidiyoruz.
O gün gerçekten belki de
bacağımı kaybettiğim günden
bile daha ağırdı benim için.
Benimle, sanki bir
çöpmüş gibi elimize verdiler.
Ve tümörü çıkartmak için
delik deşik etmişler bacağımı.
Gerçekten çok kötü bir gün
geçirdim ve eve geldim.
Dikişlerimi aldırmışım,
ameliyatımdan on beş gün geçmiş,
balkonda oturuyorum
ve o balkonda hiçbir zaman oturmam.
Ama o gün oturuyorum
ve bu kuşu gördüm balkonda…
Ona bakınca inanamadım,
onunda sol ayağı yoktu.
Mucize gibiydi, tüm evrende
gelip beni bulmuştu.
Bunun bir anlamı olmalı dedim.
Tekrar baktım,
o da bana baktı biliyor musunuz?
Ondan sonra maviliklere süzüldü.
Evet dedim;
kuşun da bir bacağı yok,
belki bir engeli var
ama onu asla kendine
engel olarak görmüyor.
O zaman ben neden
görüyorum ki diye düşündüm
ve bu kuşu gördükten
yalnızca iki gün sonra
şortumu giydim, makyajımı yaptım,
çok güzel bir makyaj yapmıştım o gün,
değneklerimi kaptım
ve alışveriş merkezine
gitmek istediğimi söyledim.
Herkes çok şaşırdı:
Neslican emin misin?
Alışveriş merkezi çok kalabalık,
şort giyeceksin, rahatsız olabilirsin.
Hayır, dedim.
O gün en çok gösterecek kıyafeti
ve en kalabalık yeri özellikle seçmiştim.
Çünkü eğer bir kere kaçarsam insanlardan,
bir kere bacağımı gizlersem
hep gizlemek isteyecektim.
Onu yapmadım
ve o korkunun üstüne gittim o gün.
Dimdik yürüyordum,
herkes bana bakıyordu
ama insanlar şaşırdıkları
için bakıyorlardı.
Çünkü;
hiç böyle bir şey gördünüz mü?
Bacağı kesik bir kız,
sargılar var ve şort giymiş.
İnsanlar çok şaşırıyordu, bana
acıdıklarını hiçbir zaman düşünmedim.
Kendimi çok güçlü
hissettim yürüdüğümde.
Hem acınacak ne var ki?
İnsanlar böyle doğabiliyor;
bacakları olmadan
belki bazı yetileri olmadan.
Ya da sonradan kaybedebiliyorlarsa
bu neden acınacak bir şey olsun ki?
Acınmamalı, ötekileştirmemeli
ve normalleşmeli bence.
O günden sonra,
hiç evde durmadım inanır mısınız?
Değnekleri kaptım
oradan oraya, oradan oraya…
İnsanlar çok şaşırıyordu
ve bana acımalarına,
beni böyle ötekileştirmelerine
hiçbir zaman izin vermiyordum.
Diyordum ki bir ortama girdiğimde;
bacaksız geldi, diyordum
ve herkes şok içinde bana
baktıklarında benim bacağım yok.
Sonra dehşete düşmüş gibi bakan insanlar
oluyordu, ben de dil çıkartıyordum
ve kendimi eksik hissetmiyordum
ve eğlenebiliyordum.
Çünkü ben eksik değilim,
tek bacaktan ibaret de değilim.
Çok daha fazlasıyım.
Bir sürü hayalim var.
Yabancı dilimi geliştiriyorum,
protezimle hâlâ uyum
sağlamaya çalışıyorum,
kansere bırakmıyorum hayatımı,
hayallerimin peşinden koşuyorum.
Bir kitap yazıyorum,
tekrar üniversiteye hazırlanıyorum.
Bir sosyal medya hesabım var
yazılarımı paylaştığım.
Çünkü ben kansere hayatımı bırakamam.
Ben daha yirmi yaşındayım
ve hayatımı, umudumu, yaşama sevincimi
hiçbir zaman kaybetmedim.
Her şeyin yoluna girdiği zamanlarda
tekrar akciğerime nüksetti maalesef.
Yılbaşına gireceğiz. 25 Aralık 2017.
Çılgın planlar yapıyorum,
çünkü ben bacağıma protezimi takmışım,
artık demir kadın oldum demişim.
Sürekli geziyorum, keşfediyorum,
öğreniyorum tam o sıralar;
yeni yıldan tek beklediğim şey sağlıktı.
Çünkü biliyorum ki ben yaşadığım için,
bir şeyleri yapmak için sadece,
planlarımızı gerçekleştirmek için
sadece sağlıklı olmaya ihtiyacımız var.
Her zaman, bu yaşadığım bir yıldan önce,
yeni yıldan aşk isterdim,
başarı isterdim,
kariyer isterdim belki,
daha hızlı koşmak
isterdim basketbol oynarken.
Ama bu sene sadece sağlık istemiştim.
Maalesef o, bunları konuştuğum,
bunları dilediğim günlerde
tekrar kanser olduğumu öğrendim.
Akciğerimin bir kısmına
nüksetmişti; sağ alt loba.
Çok şanslıyım dedim,
bu kötülükte bile iyiliği buldum
çünkü tümörüm çıkartılabiliyordu.
Bu sefer bacağımın içinde,
bacağımı bırakmadım,
bacağımı bırakmak kadar ağır değildi.
Evet belki yeni yıla bu borularla girdim
ama hayır dedim;
ben karalar bağlamayacağım.
Hayat devam ediyor.
Ben mutlu olmalıyım,
harika bir aileye sahibim,
bir sürü insana ulaşıyorum
neden mutsuz olayım ki?
Evet tümör çıkartıldı,
merak ediyorsunuz biliyorum.
Tekrar, şu an hiçbir nüks yaşamadım.
Küçük bir hapla kontrol ediliyorum.
Kemoterapinin durduramadığı
o saldırgan tümöre,
küçük bir hap ne kadar
durdurur bilmiyorum.
Ne kadar zamanımın kaldığını da.
Siz de bilmiyorsunuz.
Hiçbirimiz ne kadar zamanımızın
kaldığını bilmeden yaşıyoruz.
O zaman en güzel şekilde yaşamalıyız.
Bana bakın;
ben iki kanser atlattım,
bacağımı kaybettim
ama hiçbir zaman yaşama sevincimi,
yaşama umudumu kaybetmedim.
Çünkü hayat her zaman
yaşamaya değer,
ben bunu çok iyi biliyorum
ve bir misyona sahibim.
Bugün o yüzden buradayım:
Ailedeki en sağlıklı bireylerin bile
kanser olabileceğini anlatmak için…
Hayatında hareket etmeden
duramayan bir insanın bile
bacağını kaybettiğinde,
hayata tutunabileceğini,
demir bacaklı kadınların
gururla etek giyebileceğini
göstermek için bugün buradayım.
Herkes kanser olabilir,
herkes engelli olabilir klişesinin
arkasına sığınarak söylemiyorum hiçbirini.
Bizzat yaşamış biri olarak konuşuyorum.
Bana bakın, iyi bakın:
Şükürler olsun ki bacağım vardan
çok daha fazla şey ifade ediyorum.
Mücadeleme kulak verin,
dünyam başıma yıkıldığındaki
umudumu düşünün
ve harekete geçin.
Osho'nun söylediği gibi "Karanlık olmadan
yıldızları göremez insan."
19. yaşının tamamında yıldızları
izleyen bir kız söylüyor bunu:
"Kendi yıldızlarınızı keşfetmek için
karanlığı beklemeyin."
Hayatınızı sevin, kendinizi sevin.
Bedeninizi sevin.
Ruhunuz başka bedende bulunmayacak.
Saçlarınızı, kilonuzu, boyunuzu sevin.
Benim için sol bacağınızı da sevin.
Hayatınızı sevin,
sevebileceğiniz şekilde yaşayın
çünkü sadece ama sadece
bir tane hayatınız var
ve siz izin vermeden hiç kimse
ya da hiçbir engel,
sizi yaşamayı istediğiniz hayattan
hiç kimse engelleyemez.
Bana bakın.
Yaşadığım hiçbir şey bugün
burada olmamı engellemedi.
Bacağımı kaybettim,
demir kadın oldum dedim.
Kanserle hâlâ mücadele ediyorum
ama kansere bırakmıyorum hayatımı.
Onu küçümsüyorum, onu tiye alıyorum,
onunla dalga geçiyorum ve ben kazandım.
Şu anda buradayım, şu anda sağlıklıyım
ve emin olun, hayatta yaşadığınız
her anın bir anlamı vardır.
Ben bacağımı kaybettim
ve kansere yakalandım.
Kanser olduğumda o kemoterapi,
uzun kemoterapi zamanlarında
kendi kendimi keşfettim.
Kendi yıldızlarımı keşfettim.
Bir parçamı kaybettim
ve bir yaşam amacı edindim.
Sokakta bir insan beni durdurduğunda;
Neslican senin sayende kilomla barıştım,
Neslican ben sigarayı bıraktım.
Neslican benim bir kolum yok
ama ben artık göstermekten
korkmuyorum, dediklerinde
Tanrı'nın bacağımın neden benden
gitmesine izin verdiğini anladım.
Benim için bu çok önemli;
insanların kalbine dokunabilmek,
insanlara umut olmak,
belki örnek olmak,
belki onları hayata karşı,
istediklerine yapmaya karşı
minik kıvılcım olabilmek.
Belki üniversite sınavında,
bunların hiçbiri başıma gelmeseydi
tekrar hazırlansaydım
ve harika bir kariyerim olsaydı;
bu kadar mutlu olmayacaktım.
Her zaman böyle bakmasını bildim.
Evet kanser oldum dedim
ama bunu atlatacağım.
Atlattım.
Bacağımı kaybettim,
demir bacağım var onunla barıştım.
Çünkü hayat bundan ibaret,
hepimiz dibi görebiliriz.
Ben sağlık konusunda gördüm,
sen iş konusunda görürsün,
sen ailen konusunda görürsün,
belki kariyeriniz
konusunda görebilirsiniz.
Önemli olan dibe batmak değil,
o dipten nasıl çıktığınızdır.
Bugün buradayım.
Yarın başka bir yerde,
başka bir şekilde karşılaşabiliriz.
Bence;
bir şekilde sizin
karşınıza çıktıysam eğer
bunun da mutlaka bir anlamı vardır.
Teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz için.
(Alkışlar)